- [Narrator] Inflation is dropping
and the Federal Reserve is
holding interest rates steady,
signaling the potential for.
- A soft landing.
- Soft landing.
- Is this the soft landing?
- A soft landing is
basically economic nirvana.
They require the right
mix of policymaking skill
and just plain economic luck.
- [Narrator] But we don't
see soft landings very often
because they're hard to achieve.
Here's why.
Imagine inflation as
an airplane descending
to the ground.
When a soft landing occurs,
that essentially means
the plane, or inflation,
manages to land smoothly on
the ground without any bumps
or turbulence, which basically
means the Federal Reserve
is able to bring inflation
down to its target rate,
which is about 2% without
triggering a negative reaction,
like a recession
or significantly raising
the unemployment rate.
- There's a little bit of a problem
with a soft landing analogy.
Planes land, economies don't.
The economy is always moving,
it's growing, it's shrinking.
It's not standing still.
So then the question is
if we have a soft landing,
do you just stay there?
That's hard to do.
- [Narrator] In order to
soft land the economy,
the Fed uses its main tool
to fight inflation
raising: interest rates,
and the Fed was, until
recently, on a historic run
of raising interest
rates to a 22-year high
after a post-pandemic,
strong economic rebound pushed inflation
to more than 9% last year.
- At today's meeting, the
committee raised the target range
for the federal funds rate
by 1/4 percentage point,
bringing the target
range to 4 and 3/4 to 5%.
- When you raise interest
rates, it's a blunt instrument.
You don't get to fine tune
how much you're gonna
slow down the economy.
It isn't like lightly tapping
on the brake on the car,
you stomp on it and things can break.
The concern is that something
in the economy's going to break.
- [Narrator] The most
commonly referred to example
of a soft landing
happened in the mid-1990s
under the leadership of then
Fed Chair Alan Greenspan.
The Fed raised interest
rates rapidly between 1994
and 1995 from 3% to 6%.
Inflation and the unemployment
rate both declined.
- The data that have been published
in the first weeks of 1995
have offered some indications
that the expansion may finally
be slowing from its torrid
and unsustainable pace of late 1994.
- [Narrator] But today's economic
challenges are different.
- Inflation was not a problem
when the Fed was raising
interest rates in the mid-1990s.
They were doing a preemptive strike.
This is a completely different scenario
because the Fed has been
trying to do something
that's never been done before,
which is soft landing the economy
after a period of much higher inflation.
- [Narrator] Soft landings
are elusive for a reason
because in order to land the airplane,
you have to avoid a lot of
turbulence, like energy prices,
a hot economy, Fed rate
hikes, and financial crises.
- There are so many
unknowns in the economy.
What's gonna happen to oil prices?
Are consumers suddenly gonna feel
like they've gotten their fill
of Taylor Swift and Beyonce
and they don't need to
spend money anymore?
They're not so confident
about their income situation.
Jobs are maybe harder to
get and so they pull back.
- [Narrator] One of the primary
threats to a soft landing:
the Fed itself.
If the Fed holds rates
too tight for too long,
it could risk a severe downturn.
Inflation has cooled to 3.1%
and the unemployment rate dropped
to 3.7%, prompting the Fed
to keep interest rates steady.
- I have always felt since the beginning
that there was a possibility
because of the unusual situation
that the economy could cool off in a way
that enabled inflation to
come down without the kind
of large job losses that
have often been associated
with high inflation and tightening cycles.
- They're in wait and see mode.
They think they've probably done enough,
but they don't wanna declare victory
or mission accomplished prematurely.
It would be embarrassing
and it could be painful
for the economy if they
said they were done
and then they had to go
raise interest rates again.
- [Narrator] While the inflation rate,
or the airplane,
appears to be descending
in the right direction,
it doesn't necessarily mean the Fed
has soft landed the economy.
A lot could change at any given time.
- If we don't have a soft landing,
it's probably because we have a recession.
And then the question
is how bad does it get?
Is it a mild recession?
The other side of that is
that we don't have any kind
of downturn, and in that case,
the Fed would probably get nervous
if inflation didn't come down enough
and the economy started to regain speed.
I think the reason soft
landings are so difficult
to achieve is they just
require the right mix
of luck and skill.
It's hard to know
without seeing the future
where exactly you should
set interest rates.
(lively music)